THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON, I'M
BRET BAIER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS ABOUT TO BEGIN A BUSY
EVENING OF GLAD-HANDING AND
RALLYING THE TROOPS TONIGHT
AT HIS FLORIDA RESORT.
THE G.O.P. TROOPS THAT IS
MANY OF THE PRESIDENT'S
SUPPORTERS AND ALMOST ALL OF
HIS CRITICS ARE EXPRESSING
SERIOUS CONCERNS TONIGHT
ABOUT HIS PLAN TO LEVY NEW
TARIFFS ON IMPORTED STEEL
AND ALUMINUM LORDS AROUND
THE WORLD ARE WARMING OF A
TRADE WAR.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS BRING IT
ON.
PART OF THE PRESIDENTS' DAY
WAS SPENT OWE FUNERAL FOR
LEGENDARY EVANGELIST BILLY
GRAHAM AND THAT IS WHERE WE
START TONIGHT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
HAS OUR TOP STORY.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO
YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NEVER
BEEN ONE TO SHY AWAY FROM A
FIGHT.
HE HAS A DOOSIE ON HIS HANDS
OVER STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
♪
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
CHARLOTTE TODAY PAYING LAST
RESPECTS TO THE REVEREND
BILLY GRAHAM WHILE ACROSS
THE NATION REACTION TO HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT OF TARIFFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM KEPT
GAINING STEAM.
EVEN THE MAN WHO SAID DONALD
PRESIDENT EVER WAS STUNNED.
>> I'M VERY SURPRISED.
HE HAS HAD VERY BAD ADVICE
FROM SOMEBODY DOWN THERE.
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY THESE TARIFFS ARE
GOING TO BE THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
FRANKLY, WE DON'T WIN BY
ASSESSING TARIFFS THAT
BASICALLY COME BACK TO BITE
US.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEEMED
UNCONCERNED ABOUT
RETALIATION FROM ABROAD.
TWEETING THIS MORNING THAT
TRADE WARS ARE GOOD AND EASY
TO WIN.
THE PRESIDENT INSISTING WE
MUST PROTECT OUR COUNTRY AND
OUR WORKERS.
OUR STEEL INDUSTRY IS IN BAD
SHAPE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE STEEL, YOU
DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
WHILE HIS THREAT OF TARIFFS
PROVOKED HOWLS OF OUTRAGE
FROM NATIONS THAT SELL STEEL
AND LOOM FROM THE U.S. FROM.
OHIO DEMOCRATIC MARCI AT A
BOY.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR
THIS.
WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT FOR
THE STEEL INDUSTRY COLLAPSE
AS HAPPENED TO THE
AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE THE
ALUMINUM INDUSTRY COLLAPSE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> IT WASN'T JUST TRADE THAT
HAD POLITICAL TONGUES
WAGGING.
LAST NIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MET AGAIN WITH THE NRA
LEADERSHIP, THE SECOND TIME
THIS WEEK.
THE NRA'S CHRIS COX
TWEETING:  POTUS AND V POTUS
DON'T WANT GUN CONTROL.
THE WHITE HOUSE INSIST YOU
HAVE HAD THE PRESIDENT ISN'T
BACKTRACKING ON HIS CALLS TO
IMPROVE GUN SAFETY.
HE JUST WANTS TO HEAR FROM
ALL SIDES.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE
CLEAR HE WANTS TO TALK TO
ALL OF THE BIG STAKEHOLDERS
IN THIS PROCESS.
HE HAS SPOKEN WITH STUDENTS
WITH PARENTS, WITH TEACHERS,
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
NRA.
HE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS FEAR THE
MOMENTUM FOR CHANGE IS
ALREADY FADING.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING
IN A STATEMENT PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOULD GO WITH HIS
INSTINCTS AND NOT
INSTRUCTIVE CALL OF THE NRA.
IF HE CONTINUES TO BOW TO
HIS RIGHT WING RING MASTERS
WE WILL GET NOTHING DONE ON
GUNS AND HIS PRESIDENCY WILL
CONTINUE TO FAIL.
AND THE CONTROVERSY
SURROUNDING THE FIRING OF
FORMER STAFF SECRETARY ROB
PORTER BUBBLED UP AGAIN
TODAY WHEN CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN KELLY FILLED IN SOME
BLANKS FOR REPORTERS AT A
PEN AND PAD SESSION.
KELLY SAYING THE FIRST HE
HEARD ABOUT ALLEGATIONS OF
SPOUSAL ABUSE WAS AS THE
ABOUT 5:00 P.M. ON TUESDAY,
FEBRUARY 6TH, INVOLVING
PORTER'S SECOND WIFE.
KELLY WENT TO SEE PORTER WHO
TOLD HIM HE WOULD RESIGN.
ABOUT 90 MINUTES LATER,
AFTER A QUICK TRIP TO
CAPITOL HILL, KELLY LEARNED
OF A SECOND ALLEGATION.
THIS TIME FROM PORTER'S
FIRST WIFE.
PORTER ASSURED KELLY THERE
WAS NOTHING TO THE
ALLEGATIONS BUT KELLY
INSISTED PORTER HAD TO
RESIGN.
THAT NIGHT, AND THE NEXT
DAY, THE WHITE HOUSE
RELEASED SEVERAL STATEMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF PORTER THE.
EVEN THOUGH HE HAD
EFFECTIVELY BEEN FIRED.
>> HE IS GOING TO BE LEAVING
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WON'T BE IMMEDIATE BUT HE
IS RESIGNING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE BUT ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A SMOOTH TRANSITION
MOVING FORWARD.
>> KELLY TOOK THE BLAME FROM
THAT SAYING HE HAD NOT FULLY
BRIEFED THE PRESS OFFICE OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
WHEN HE PHOTO OF HIS EX-WIFE
WITH A BLACK EYE.
HE REVEALED THAT PORTER HAD
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
KELLY ALSO SAID NEITHER HE
NOR WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON
MCGAHN WERE AWARE THE FBI
HAD SENT INFORMATION ABOUT
PORTER'S SECURITY CLEARANCE
FILE TO THE WHITE HOUSE IN
BOTH MARCH AND JULY.
KELLY TOLD REPORTERS TODAY
THAT HE NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT
RESIGNING OVER THE PORTER
ISSUE SAYING THAT HE ACTED
QUICKLY WHEN HE LEARNED
ABOUT IT AND DID THINGS AS
APPROPRIATELY AS HE THOUGHT
HE COULD, SAYING THAT IT WAS
NOTHING TO CONSIDER
RESIGNING OVER.
BUT, KELLY DID ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE COULD
HAVE HANDLED THE SITUATION
BETTER, TELLING REPORTERS,
QUOTE:  WE DIDN'T COVER
OURSELVES IN GLORY IN TERMS
OF HOW WE HANDLED THAT ON
WEDNESDAY MORNING.
IT WAS CONFUSING.